STEVEN HALL: So there
are a couple challenges
that you need to
think about when
you're using this approach.
One is it's important to
explain to the students what's
going on.
If you just start
doing this and say,
this is what we're
going to do, and don't
tell the students why
you're going to do it,
that's problematic.
I think it's important to think
of the students as partners.
Explain what's going on, they're
much more likely to buy into it
and maybe get used
to the new approach.
One of the things I do
is I present some data,
because it's MIT and students
are persuaded by data.
And what the data says is
that generally the more active
a learning exercise, the
more that students learn.
And there's some
really good data
in the literature
that shows that,
so I explain to students that
the reason I'm doing this
is to increase their
level of understanding,
especially at the
conceptual level as opposed
to the analytic level of
just doing a problem using,
the equations.
STUDENT: I've never had a
recitation like this before.
Actually working on
problems with everybody else
and kind of going through
and struggling through it,
but eventually
understanding a lot better
what was done in lecture
through, I guess, a more hands
on approach.
STEVEN HALL: Do the
students like this?
Well, I have a little
bit of feedback.
I do think that, initially,
they're apprehensive.
They're not used to being
so exposed in the classroom.
They can hide, usually.
If they don't want
to answer a question,
they don't raise their hand.
But in a situation like this,
everyone's answer is visible.
So initially, I do think they
are a little bit uncomfortable.
I think they get
comfortable very quickly
and get used to it.
At the end of the day, at
the end of the class when
they evaluate it, I've
found that students really
like this approach, that they
like this sort of recitation
much more than
conventional recitations,
and often comment about that
in the course evaluation.
So even though there
might be a little bit
of initial reluctance, I think
most students would really
like this approach.